under the sea that's a good song music
people in American divers set a new
record for the deepest dive in history
Viktor Baskov Oh plunged nearly 36,000
feet in his water craft to the lowest
part of the ocean in the Pacific's
Mariana Trench last month now this is
only the third time that humans have
been able to reach the seas extreme
depths molla lanky spoke to vest boat
vest Cobo about his surprising discovery
in the deepest natural trench on the
planet mola good morning please help me
with his name Viktor visco let's go yeah
you got it exactly a tale of adventure
here good morning guys the private
equity investor we spoke with is a
thrill seeker to say the least he has
skied the North and South Poles and
conquered the highest peaks on all seven
continents including Mount Everest but
after reaching the highest place on
earth he was also determined to reach
the lowest deep in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean
Viktor vests kavod of 35,000 853 feet
beneath the waves breaking previous
records by about 36 feet congratulations
Victor thank you
the Dallas investors spent four hours
exploring the deepest known area of the
planet seabed in a 48 million dollar
submersible a small watercraft built to
withstand the extreme pressure of the
ocean's depths we wanted to prove the
capabilities of the submarine in the
whole system by diving there repeatedly
and really hopefully opening a door for
science though vesco vu is the first to
make it this far down man's impact has
already been felt with pieces of plastic
scattered among the sea creatures and
most of the deeps I've been down
contamination of plastic or stings I
can't even recognize but they're
definitely man-made which is really
unfortunate vest Evo and his team saw a
pink snailfish multiple kinds of eel and
also discovered at least three new
species he says their genetic
information could advance medical
research it feels like a great privilege
that I was able to do this as a human
being it's a great feeling just to try
and you know help push humanity a little
bit for it that's up on the surface one
giant dive for mankind
well vesco Bo's next challenge is to
reach the bottom of the Arctic Ocean
which he plans to do in August a
documentary series that chronicles his
expedition will air on the Discovery
Channel later this year and once he has
conquered the mountains and the oceans
guys he says his next challenge is outer
space I believe you'll do it tell the
channel I can all right